and this particular example we're going
to rotate this triangle ABC 120 degrees
about this point P using a protractor
and a compass so what I'm going to show
you here is first thing you want to do
is you want to draw some lines and we're
going to start by drawing a line from
the point that we're rotating about
point P to vertex a so I'm just going to
start by drawing a line okay and then
what you want to do is you want to
position your protractor so that the
point P here is right at the center here
of your your protractor that's the point
in rotating about you also want to make
sure that this line here between point P
and point a is along this edge okay and
so now we want to make sure we use the
right numbers so you can see there's a
set of numbers on the inside of the
protractor our numbers on the outside of
the protractor we're rotating
counterclockwise so we're going to start
over here the with the numbers on the
outside zero degrees 10 degrees 20
degrees and you can see until we get to
120 degrees over here I'm gonna put a
mark and I'm gonna draw a line through
the point of the center of rotation
point P to that 120 degree mark so you
just draw a line along that 120 degree
mark there so now what you can do is you
can use your compass and what you want
to do is you want to open it up in such
a way that it reaches from the center of
rotation point P to this vertex a okay
and what you can do is you can rotate
that along that 120 degree line and now
you can see that the distance from P to
a is gonna be the same as the distance
from P to a prime a prime means it's
that our new point there so we're gonna
repeat that process with B and C and
then we're gonna connect all those
points together to get our new figure so
let me just walk through that again with
you so we're gonna draw a light line
through the center of rotation point P
to vertex B so I'll draw a line like
that then we want to do is want to
position our protractor so that the
center of the rotation is right here and
then the edge okay is along that line
between P and and B and we want to
rotate 120 degrees so I'm starting on
the outside of the pork tractor going
counterclockwise 120 degrees I put a
mark right here at 120 degree mark and I
draw a line through the center of
rotation P out through that hundred
when a degree line like so then we use
our compass and we measure essentially
we open it up in such a way that the
distance from point P to to be that
distance is going to be the same as from
P to P prime okay now I didn't make my
line long enough so let me just extend
it a little bit here and so you can see
they're crossing right there that's B
Prime and we want to do the same thing
with point C so let me see if I can draw
that line now we've got P to C okay like
so and now what I want to do is I want
to position my protractor so the center
is right at point P and the edge is
right along this line between P and C
and so if I measure 10 20 30 40 all the
way to 120 degrees that's 122 remark
right there draw a line through the
vertex or the center of rotation I
should say out through that point okay
so let's see that looks like it's going
to be something like that okay and it's
good to make your lines a little bit
longer than you think you need just so
you don't have to go back and extend it
like I did on that last one and so what
you can do now is use your compass to
measure that distance from P to C okay
looks and we have that pretty good there
and then we rotate around make an arc
and you can see it's across from right
there that's gonna be the location of C
prime now all we have to do is connect a
prime B Prime and C prime together and
let's see if that looks congruent to our
original triangle it should be the
exactly the same size and shape it
should be exactly congruent it just
should be rotated now 120 degrees so
let's see if that makes sense okay let's
go see that in sweet I said everything
right here as we can see this is
actually a turn there's no length on
think you're at Point P can I take a
speaker and rotate it okay 120 degrees
counterclockwise you can see that that
would be our image here this is our pre
image so if you want to see more
examples where I do different types of
constructions in geometry I'll link to a
playlist that you can check out if you
want to see more of my videos I look
forward to helping you over in those
future videos and I'll I'll talk to you
soon